meanwhile the vice president kamala
harris is going to finally see the
border crisis
firsthand tomorrow three months after
being tapped to lead the
administration's response
harris will head to el paso texas along
with homeland security chief
alejandro mayorkas critics are
questioning the timing with former
president trump
already announced he's going to visit
the border next week texas congressman
tony gonzalez from
the el paso area joins us live good
morning to you sir
hey good morning steve good to have you
uh you are the congressman for that
region also
uh but you're not going to be there
you're not going to be there to show her
what she's missing
uh but instead she's probably going to
be welcomed by veronica escobar
who has been very a democrat uh unlike
henry cuer who's been very critical
of the administration she has been very
supportive
yeah you know i'm hearing the vice
president is isn't going to be on the
ground very long only a few hours
matter of fact the flight to el paso is
going to be longer than the time
that she's going to be on the ground and
that's that's really unfortunate
uh but you know what i i am excited that
she's at least shown up
uh you know kevin mccarthy and a bunch
of us uh visited back in march
steve scalise has done the same you know
leadership is about showing up
but really it's it's now what you know
what they're gonna see
uh hopefully is not just a photo op
they're gonna hear that fentanyl is
coming over at record numbers
you know uh unaccompanied children over
80 000 unaccompanied children
over 800 000 migrants so uh and now it's
it's the now what factor
sure you know and for now for the
administration to admit okay she's going
to go down and see the crisis with her
own two eyes
wait a minute there's a crisis they've
tried to pretend like this is not a big
problem uh my orcis has said the
strategy is working although
that puzzles everybody but why el paso
you know if we heard in a couple of
sound bites a little while ago if she
really wanted to see it go to donna
texas to see the place
that was referred to as kids in cages
but instead she's going to el paso
so what's she going to see there yeah
you really can't be a border security
expert
if you're on the ground for two hours
you know you got to put some effort into
this and
uh the reality is el paso the el paso
sector
is very different than rio grande valley
or del rio
or the big bend sector or the laredo
sector they all are different
and in order to understand this crisis
you have to understand that all parts of
the border
are different uh you know her showing up
and taking a photo op
getting back on a plane as fast as she
can it's disrespectful as well
but what i'm really what i really like
to see is this administration has to be
held accountable
for title 42. if they do away with title
42
as bad as things are now you're going to
see them get worse
well it sounds like they're going to
title 42 allowed border patrol people to
say at the
southern border hey stop there's a
pandemic you got to go back to mexico it
sounds like because
uh the aclu is challenging them in court
they're going to
go ahead and quietly get rid of it so
that they do not have to defend
the donald trump policies which they did
not want to do but speaking of donald
trump congressman you know
this 100 is true the reason she is going
tomorrow
is because donald trump announced he was
going to go down to the southern border
with greg
abbott next week that's right i mean we
have we have put
uh political pressure on her for months
and months and months to show up
uh you know thankfully former president
donald trump's coming down
and and i all of a sudden you know you
put you put their head in a political
vice
and then they start moving uh but you
know like i said i'm glad she's really
showing up but now what you know she
needs to
uh we need actions all right tony
gonzalez
joining us today from the dc area he's
got some votes that's why it's not going
to be down
in texas tomorrow sir thank you very
much thanks steve
you bet